our next guest is no stranger to the big
screen y'all Abdul Mateen the second
play the villain Black Manta in the
super hero movie Aquaman he has also
been in Thrillers like ambulance
Candyman hit TV series Watchmen and
Matrix resurrections now you can add
Broadway star to his very impressive
resume he'll make his Broadway debut in
the Revival of Top Dog Underdog opening
later this month it tells a story of Two
Brothers Lincoln and Booth as they
battle with their past and desire to be
the best at three card Monty if you
don't know that's the trick card game
Yaya Abdul Mateen II is here joining us
right now good morning how you doing I'm
doing great I'm doing excellent it's a
pleasure you like that yeah we're glad
you're here we're big fans now you call
this the the ultimate role for you why
oh uh man I found this uh this row
about 16 years ago it was the very first
contemporary piece of theater that I
ever felt was um
that I found myself in you know I used
to Shakespeare used to be my thing and
then I found this and I said oh they
talk like me I know these people and so
I found my comfort zone in this space
and this was the first piece of theater
that really uh embraced me for who I was
and uh that was about 16 years 16 years
ago it was this thing yeah well you were
in college at the time right yeah yeah I
was an undergraduate you went to
University of California Berkeley to
study architecture and then you end up
in a theater class on a dare yeah
something like that uh I was I was on
the track team and uh
really good friend of mine he sort of
said uh
he said uh he said dude you should take
a theater class it's just like recess
[Laughter]
I'm like you know okay okay you know I'm
down for that I like recess I like
recess like an elective course in
college exactly just like that you know
what I mean and um and I went in and the
theater space really embraced me and as
soon as I found that space uh the world
that Avenue just opened up wow and and
you know the land are you in touch with
that friend who said that I haven't
talked to JP in about 15 years but I
should probably send him a note I talk
about him a lot I wonder what he thinks
about it
but let's talk about the role because
it's so intense I went the other night I
was in seat row G seat one and 102. did
you see me oh yeah yeah that was me I
bought a filter yes I was very subtle
but the role is so intense lashawn's
happened to be there that night she's
one of the producers and she says you
should see how he prepares he comes to
the theater every day an hour and a half
early that he really it's your first
role and you take it extremely seriously
what are you doing when you come an hour
and a half what is your process to get
ready because it's intense I don't know
you get that intensity it depends on the
day
um but you know I'm doing eight shows a
week so you got to take care of your
instrument of course hydrating I'm doing
boring stuff like yoga and stretching
and ah and doing all of that stuff but
then also just getting my mind ready get
him back in touch with the character
reminding myself of why I'm doing this
play you know I want I want the Lincolns
and the booths to be able to come to the
theater and to see themselves on that
stage and then say oh somebody's telling
our story I see myself up there as a
human and also when Lincoln and Booth
come to this play they're likely not
going to be sitting in in CG they're
going to be sitting way way up there in
the back you know making sure that they
catch it all so I want to be able to
have my instrument ready to make sure
that they can feel everything that I'm
giving off other thing yeah is that I
like a play that's lights camera action
this is a play play it's just the two of
you on stage the whole time one scene
and I find sometimes those players are
Hearts but it's so it's written so well
it's directed so well and all that is a
testament to you and Corey the
preparation that you appreciate that
into Susan Lloyd Parks as well you know
into our fabulous director Kenny Leon
Susan Lloyd Park said something the
other night and it'll always stick with
me she said I wrote this place so that
brother's like you can shine you know
yeah and and it gives me the opportunity
to do that it gives Corey the
opportunity to do that um and I'm sure
that someone's going to see this play
and they're going to be inspired to want
to be an actor of course uh uh um and to
find themselves into the future also
talk about shining because you're also a
Calvin Klein underwear model
you remove your clothes and you sit here
and do the rest do your research
we have a producer who shall remain
nameless Wendy and she said Yaya is
coming today I mean she started shaking
her shoulders and everything oh yeah she
wasn't only anything I was doing that
this morning
so what does it mean what does that part
of your life mean to you are you having
fun with that do you just think okay
yeah I got this what's what's your
thought process for that uh so I'm doing
my teeth processes you know control the
carbs and make sure that I cry you know
make sure that I you know hit my
push-ups right and uh it look good but
no I mean it's fun you know all of that
is is you know this acting thing really
opened up so many avenues for me uh to
take care of myself to be able to take
care of my family to step into dreams
and and and and and and you know uh
different parts of life that I always
grew up watching but never really had a
desire for I never really thought that I
would take part in and now I'm here
right now
and I get to do cool things like Calvin
Klein yes well you're a talented guy and
a disciplined man you know we got tacos
over there we made it in the last
segment on the way out dreams you know
what I was looking at the tacos today's
my day off so okay okay
we'll be right back thank you very much